how do you take on someone who literally
fights to fight I mean I I know you saw
2016 you saw 2020 Donald Trump is a
master at it what's your game plan I
can't play as a civil one I'm running
for president United States and I plan
to be the nominee so the good news is
for the American people you will have a
stark contrast between me and the rest
of the field I look forward to being the
messenger that actually adds to our
party without deluding our conservative
values listen you um you how exactly are
you going to be doing brain transplant
surgery in five years when you're not in
medical school we don't have brain
transplant surgery as a procedure that
is done like how exactly are you going
to do it well listen five years are
going to go by and then I'm going to be
doing brain transplants oh wow I guess I
never thought about it that way that's
the absurdity of what Tim Scott is
saying here